why are American politicians so old
the debate around gerontocracy
or a government based on the rule of old people
is being brought back up
as two of America's oldest politicians
senators Mitch McConnell and Diane Feinstein
headlines after videos caught them being
seemingly confused on the job
during a press conference
McConnell who is 81 years old
and has a history of medical episodes
unexpectedly froze mid sentence
a day later Feinstein
who is 90 years old
seemingly forgot how to vote yes on a bell
with her colleagues rushing to her side
yeah just say okay just
why Feinstein was also criticized earlier in the year
after taking a three month hiatus from the Senate
due to health issues
with many in her own party
suggesting that she should step down
as she wasn't present to vote in fact
America's current Senate buddy is the oldest in history
a median age of 65 years old
and to be clear
while the median age is that of a boomer
Feinstein and McConnell are not part of that generation
but are actually part of the Silent Generation
or those born between 1925 to 1945
also in the Silent Generation is President Joe Biden
who is the only American president to turn 80 in office
if he wins the 2024 election and serves a full term
he'll be 85 years old when he leaves at White House
it's been a main point of attack for Republicans
who have views Biden's semen confusion
on several occasions
has a reason to impeach him
but former President Donald Trump isn't young either
he was born in 1946
the first year of the boomer generation
for context
the global average age of elected officials
sits at 53 years old